so Halloween is coming up I know you got
kiddos um so so what do y'all do you do
you dress cuz I I know that we had the
cute little photos of your children but
I also found this one of you and I just
have a quick question Here Andrew
um like what I don't know that I've ever
known a kid that dresses is the Pope the
pope yeah you're a very serious kid it's
a very Catholic idea my brother and his
family are here so he was withing this
family hi um so yeah Grandma Josephine
had this idea that I was going to be the
pope so she put together that costume
she got me and I was the pope and my
little sister Natalie was an angel but
it was like but it's still like hands
down I'm 45 that's my best Halloween
costume oh my God I love you the Pope I
just fourth grade can you imagine trick-
or- tree I've just never seen a kid
dressed as the pope as the pope it was I
was very popular like Tony Stark popular
people took a lot of pictures with me it
was like yeah I felt you were a hit I
was a hit okay well I have to pull this
one up to this was last year and this
was incredible this was this is
incredible I mean them and Jet what's
really what's really complicated what's
really complicated about this picture is
I was also trying to be the
pope it is tricky they're layers some
something went very wrong someone LED
you astray no I lost a bet with my
daughters I lost a bet they said if you
lose this bet you have to be Ursula for
Halloween and so I ended up being Ursula
for Halloween please tell me you walked
around trick-or-treating with them
singing Poor Unfortunate Souls 100% okay
you would have let me down oh yeah do
you like to dress up orig Halloween I
love to dress up I love a theme I don't
even want to go to a party unless it's
themed like like why hang in general you
don't like to go to any parties unless
you're themed or just Halloween I'm
let's be real like I I'm sorry I can't
attend your wedding unless everybody's
dressed up as a character I did wait I
did throw a themed party one time though
and Enrique glacia showed up because we
had the same manager at the time I don't
hang out with famous people I'm not cool
and I but he showed up and he wasn't in
costume and at that point I'd had a lot
to drink and so I was very bold and
walked up and was like get out you know
I'm a
c I was like you have to wear a costume
to be here and I was like I'm just
kidding but kind of get out also get a
[Music]
costume
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home